[Music]
overnight I went from being a completely
private figure to a publicly humiliated
one worldwide I was patient zero of
losing a personal reputation on the
global scale almost instantaneously
that's Monica Lewinsky speaking very
candidly in a 2015 TED talk about
becoming the center of a national
scandal she was just twenty four years
old when the news first broke online
back in 1998 about her relationship with
then President Bill Clinton now that led
to years of harassment on the Internet
the experience prompted Lewinsky to join
the fight against cyber bully now she's
collaborated with anti-bullying groups
in a video you're seeing first on CBS
this morning
it shows how we treat each other online
versus in the real world homosexuality
is a disease we're saving humanity by
killing itself out of you right now
[Music]
this woman is dangerous all Muslims are
terrorists yeah that moves the terms
[Music]
fine that's really mean are you okay
[Music]
Monica Lewinsky joins us live and in
color here at the table Monica good to
see you good morning good morning gal I
remember your TED talk back in 2015 and
I remember thinking yeah good for you
speaking up and here you are again 2017
and you always point out that speaking
up is never something that you like to
do you're not seeking the spotlight
you're not trying to put yourself in the
public eye but this topic matters to you
I have sweaty palms right now so I'm
very nervous this is not always easier
but you're in good hands here but this
is a very important topic and as as you
just saw with the PSA this is very much
about showing the disparity between how
we behave online and how we behave
offline when we're face to face but you
decide yourself back it back then as
patient zero because yes you were cyber
bullied before we even knew what cyber
bullying was we didn't we didn't even
have a term for cyber bullying or online
harassment or even slut-shaming so what
happened to you what just we don't have
to go into all the details but thank you
we're not to go into all the details but
what happened to you and how you got
through it well I think that you know
the back then it was the nascent days
really of the internet we didn't have
social media yet but there were there
were certainly online sorry there were
online websites for news and there were
comment sections and websites on which
people could comment so it became a very
new world in which people could
communicate their thoughts and I think
we started to see then and we start to
see even more now what psychologist John
solar calls the online disinhibition
effect where people lose their they lose
their sense of self in a way because of
the anonymity and behind this they would
never get dry face you know exactly you
know what's so interesting to me and why
I connect so much with the PSA that
we've done and the rest of the campaign
is that I realized I couldn't count on
one hand how many times people have said
cruel and truly hateful things to me
online but when I realized I could count
one maybe two hands the number of times
that people have actually been cruel to
my face and that was really surprising
so that chasm or that disparity and
dissonance is really what's at the heart
of this campaign of what what's amazing
about it to beyond your what you
experienced is it it drives people to
suicide it does
you know we Charlie it's I don't know if
if you're all aware that we actually now
have a new word in our lexicon which is
bully side which talks about the people
who have died by suicide as a result of
bullying and their you know recent
statistics have talked about how I think
it's 20 percent of teen suicides have
been related to bullying issues and you
all might have seen to that that we're
at an all-time high in the last 40 years
for young girls and people like suicide
what do we do well with this campaign
what we are advocating is to click with
compassion and there are three
components to that so the first one is
really thinking about before you post
something online think about what you're
clicking think before you click and so
what that means is think about the face
test you know would you say that to
someone offline just as we're sitting
here and if not then don't post it next
to that really is that bullying has the
kind of the core in what fuels billon
bullying is shame and public humiliation
so
clickbait which we're all pretty
familiar with is also fueled by those
same things so another way to click with
compassion is to not click on clickbait
that we're seeing so we can contribute
to an algorithm which supports culture
of compassion versus a culture of
humiliation a large part of the focus
and rightly so is on children right
children at school being cyber bullied
how parents should deal with that but
you talk about 40 percent of American
adults experience some form of cyber
bully as well how can that be dealt with
and it's a different from how we deal
with children who are bullied online I
think you know with children of course
one of the areas of focus right now is
something called digital resilience but
I think that that applies to to adults
as well
where I think there's a slight
difference we see a little bit less of
the violence with children particularly
women and members of the LGBTQ community
experience more online violence threats
from online harassment one of the things
and really sort of another part of that
click with compassion campaign is about
using your click to support someone
who's a target of bullying online it's
very I I can relate to this from Maria
duei of even hearing from a stranger to
show support to a target can actually
really shift the situation and make sure
that you don't feel alone which is when
the word - of strangers really makes a
difference at a time like this you
talked about being bullied when you were
in sixth grade Monica yes I mean and
then it just continued to talk about the
difference between sixth grade - what
happened to you back in 1998 yes well I
was I mean I was lucky because the
bullying in a sense in sixth grade was
not as bad as as many people have it but
it was certainly scarring for me and I
think what I thought everybody knew
about it is not everybody knew about it
and that's that's a really big issue is
that there's no border on the internet
so there's there's kind of no parameter
around how many people it feels like are
laughing at you
I think what happened later on back in
1998 you know was there was no role
model there was no playbook no one else
had gone through a public shaming online
like what I had experienced and so I was
very blessed in terms of having an
incredible family and friends and I also
heard from a lot of strangers so which
connects really to the other part of the
campaign with it hashtag be strong
emojis which it's mouthful but which
came from this experience I had of
having gotten letters from strangers and
some you wouldn't want to read on TV but
a lot of them were letters of compassion
and support and that really helped me
through some times that was what got me
through a day why did the supportive
strangers make a difference and you
should know as you sit here today you
have a lot of people pulling for you
Monica they do you have a lot of people
pulling you and who are wishing you well
why did the the the
kindness of strangers matter so much
when you had as you said a good support
team you know I think it comes from and
this might get a little woowoo
but I think it comes from sorry I think
that this kind of comes from our
collective cohesiveness you know the
sort of all oneness and we are all
connected and I know that we especially
in today's world we tend to focus so
much more on our differences but we
really have so much more in common and
when you hear from a stranger there's
there's a reminder that you're a human
being and I deserve some level of
dignity one of the things that's
interesting about you and I think you've
may have said this in the TED talk is
the idea that you weren't going to
insist on a different ending to my story
you were going to change the narrative
in terms of where it was going right
well I think one of the things which is
really important for anybody who is
suffering right now from online
harassment or cyber bullying or bullying
or something that was embarrassing -
exactly exactly I think is to know that
is that we can take back our narratives
we can hold on to our narratives and as
you said we can insist on a different
ending to our story it's not it's not
always easy there's and I think it can
be very scary at times - to step out and
to try to do that but I'm incredibly
grateful that I've been able to do this
the last several yeah Charlie's question
is that part of what this is about
changing the narrative to your story I
think for me the focus really is you
know there were many times over the last
two decades when I wasn't sure I would
make it and so I can really relate in a
way to how a lot of people are feeling
in today's world even though it's for
different reasons and now we have social
media so for me this sense of being able
to use some of my experiences to help
other people is in an impactful way I'm
incredibly grateful thank you for coming
you made it Monica you've opened a
national debate to us thank you so much
thank you so much thank you for giving
time to this topic